- speaker this morning I have spoken to  circum Derek I have told him that it is  a matter of great regret that he has  felt it necessary to leave his position  the the whole cabinet rightly gave its  full support to sukira on Tuesday so  King has given so Kim has given a  lifetime of service to the United  Kingdom and we owe him an enormous debt  of gratitude  good government depends on public  servants being able to give full and  frank advice I want all our public  servants to have the confidence to be  able to do that and I hope the house  will reflect on the importance of  defending our values and principles  particularly when they are under  pressure